en este vídeo tenemos ahora un entero lo
llamaremos un entero
el cual está siendo dividido en cinco
partes iguales por lo que le colocaremos
a cada una de estas partes iguales que
es un quinto un quinto
un quinto un quinto
un quinto y un quinto de esta manera
tenemos cinco quintos que nos completan
un entero nosotros vamos a dibujar en
color azul
tres de estos quintos así es que
dibujaremos
uno de estos quintos
quintos
y colocaremos eso aquí abajo tenemos 3
en color azul de las cinco posibilidades
ok y de esta manera podemos saber que
tenemos tres de esas cinco partes
iguales tenemos tres quintos
ahora vamos a tomar un entero completo
de nuevo y lo moveré para arriba
éste también lo llamaremos un entero un
entero
si yo dibujo en azul una de las partes
iguales que tenemos pues dibujaré todo
el entero están de acuerdo porque lo
tenemos dividido únicamente en una sola
parte así es que si yo lo dibujo
con azul se verá como algo así
perfecto y entonces tengo 1 de 1 y de
hecho no sé si existan como los 11 pero
ustedes lo pueden llamar así tendremos 1
de 1 vamos a ponerlo también aquí abajo
en el que yo pueda representar que tengo
una de esas partes dibujada en azul de
un total de 11 sobre 11 unos vamos a
copiar esto y vamos a pegarlo de tal
manera que tengamos ahora 3 de ellos
ahora tenemos tres de estos unos todo
esto nos va a representar una sola cosa
y a ver te lo vamos a ver tenemos uno
sobre uno más uno sobre uno más uno
sobre uno tenemos tres unos lo colocaré
así como tres unos o también lo podemos
llamar tres enteros
enteros de hecho si bien en esta
fracción tenemos el número de arriba que
es el numerador más grande que el
denominador y con eso también lo podemos
ver como una división 3 entre 1 es igual
a 3 enteros o al número 3 y quiero hacer
énfasis en esto porque es importante que
ustedes sepan que un número sobre 1 está
hablando de enteros que estamos tomando
una de la una parte que tenemos
disponible por lo tanto tendremos 3 de
ellas en este ejemplo y lo tomaremos
como el número 3
aquí estamos sumando quintos un quinto
más un quinto más un quinto son tres
quintos pero cuando sumamos enteros
tenemos uno sobre uno más uno sobre uno
más uno sobre uno tenemos tres sobre uno
puede hacer énfasis en esto y quiero que
lo vean dentro de una recta numérica
vamos a hacer una recta numérica donde
empecemos en el cero
y nos vayamos quedó mucho puesto lo
puedo hacer mejor
mucho mejor y nos vayamos hasta el
número 31
y aquí estará el 2 y llegamos al número
3 si nosotros representamos un entero
nos indica que tomaremos una de una
parte es decir haremos un brinco del
entero completo
pero en este caso tenemos otro entero
tenemos otro brinco completo al
siguiente entero y tenemos uno más
recuerda que les decía que llegaríamos
al número 3 pues aquí estamos recuerda
en esta parte hicimos un primer salto
que nos llevó al 1 sobre 1 o este primer
entero que tenemos
pero
tuvimos un segundo entero completo lo
que nos hará hacer un segundo salto y
llegaremos al dos sobre uno o dos unos
que les decía tal vez no existan pero
para este ejemplo nos funcionan y el
tercer entero así es que hicimos un
último salto que nos llevó al 3 sobre 13
unos como lo teníamos representado aquí
tres enteros lo que es exactamente igual
al número tres